i was excited to win the best host once
it was historic and i also wanted to win
for monty
monte was the guy that that approached
me
and said i would love it if you would
take over
my baby to be a black man that was
approached by someone of monty's stature
come on that's that's amazing so it's no
small feat when i get my name mentioned
in any
way shape or form in this art form
and get recognized for it i know that
there's someone at home some kid
watching me watching kevin fraser
watching nichelle turner or or or
michael or cedric the entertainer or
steve watching us and going oh
i can do that too
and that's deep wayne's career has
spanned from tv to film music to
broadway he's earned five emmys along
the way where do you keep your enemies
i keep miami's in my studio
um on a on a shelf
and i always laugh when i hear you know
big stars
well i keep my oscar
it's a door right doorstop or i keep it
in the bathroom to remind myself
to be humble
forget that i want you to see them
i busted my ass out of orlando florida
worked every crappy job that i could so
that i could be on your tv every day so
give me my flowers is there a deal out
there that you have been offered that
you wish you had taken i wish i would
have taken curtain one years ago right
after i got whose line is it anyway
jamie foxx reached out to me and took me
to dinner and asked me to work on a
sketch show with him and
i said no
and
to this day i was like oh man i really
wish because i feel that jamie foxx and
i should be best friends i want to be
jamie foxx's buddy wayne's up against
steve harvey pat sajak and leah remini
for outstanding game show host we'll see
if he wins when the daytime emmys air
tomorrow night on cbs the emmys were all
back together it is cool to be in that
room it's cool to be in the room i'll be
at the back of the room with a mask on
uh standing right by the well-ventilated
door but it's cool
you're like i'm not messing around you
will not get playing man when i won best
host yep i didn't have a speech prepared
and my daughter and i wanted to go on a
date she wanted to walk walk the red
carpet and hang out we're sitting like
two kids like like like we're sitting
down in our seats
and now the nominees and i remember
saying yeah this is funny you know i'm
not going to win so after i don't win
let's get up and oh let's let's go get
chick-fil-a wayne brady
[Music]
[Laughter]
please wrap it up you know what it took
me nine years to get here suck it
will you improv your um speech if you
win at the emmys or will you write
something out i probably won't win so
i'll just give you a brief brief uh here
we go again i'll say wow this is uh this
is so unexpected i uh i i want to thank
everybody in the category you're all
brilliant and uh i could not win this
award without
everyone that makes let's make a deal oh
yeah snoop once said it you know what i
want to thank me
because i did this
[Music]
you